Welcome back.
In this lesson, we're going to go over
online customer acquisition techniques.
You can achieve many different goals
with online advertising but we'll be
focusing on customer acquisition rather
than brand awareness, for example.
>> So we're going to divide
this lesson into two parts.
Now in the first half,
we're going to talk about paid
tools to acquire new customers.
Such as SEM, programmatic media buying,
affiliate marketing,
social media marketing,
which includes video marketing.
>> Then we'll go into free
customer acquisition tools and
talk about engaging
with your community and
inbound marketing including content
generation and email marketing.
So let's get started with
some background information
about the three engines of growth.